look at Philadelphia this morning the
headquarters of Urban Outfitters that is
the newest fashion company to get into
the rental business Rent the Runway and
Taylor Express and American Eagle are
already renting clothing to customers
for a monthly subscription price the
online clothing rental market is
expected to reach listen to this one
point eight five billion dollars
worldwide by 2023 that's according to
Allied market research USA Today
business reporter Cherise Jones is here
to show how the business of renting
clothing is really changing the retail
game good to see you Charisse good to
see you you guys are like this I want
the green room and say how did we get
you hot we were so lucky to have you on
Memorial Day holiday how did we get you
she said I had nothing to do we are so
glad you were here at the table thank
you so let's talk about this running of
the clothes because did it start with
did they look at the success of Rent the
Runway and say hey they're onto
something here I mean I think that's
part of it I mean I think retailers are
always looking for a new revenue stream
and this is a way to kind of get new
customers and give a new option to old
customers right because we're in an
economy where everybody shares
everything right you share bicycles with
city bike you share overs you share your
house with Airbnb yeah so clothing is
kind of the next frontier and we're also
in the age of Instagram so you want to
mix up that wardrobe a little bit too
and so all of this really appeals to its
the fast fashion thing that's driving
this in some ways right exactly it is
but you know with fast fashion it can
get very wasteful yeah and a lot of
folks don't feel comfortable wearing an
outfit like once or twice and then
putting it in the closet or tossing it
in the trash yeah this way you get to
use it and then pass it on to somebody
else you know Stella McCartney said
something really interesting about the
fast fashion she said most people only
wear the clothes three times and then
they get rid of it and there's over five
five hundred million dollars worth of
waste exactly the issue right I never
thought about it the best fashion is
driven by the fact that these clothes
are pre cheap they're not often they're
sometimes they're made to just be worn a
few times and you get rid of them yeah
if if something is worn two or three
times are there confident that there's a
market of people out there
who want to wear clothes that have been
on someone else's back well I mean
obviously it's working out because
people want to like have a different
outfit for every Instagram shot right so
if something is lasting for two or three
months that's the season somebody else
can use that somebody else can use that
so you can keep passing it on they clean
it I'm a laundress I clean it they have
laundry services so they make sure that
they try to maintain it and if not then
they toss it and get something else so
how does this work is this economically
sort of is it a good deal for customers
I mean I think you can get one outfit
for a hundred dollars so you can get
five outfits for a hundred dollars right
so Ribbon Outfitters is charging eighty
eight dollars to get six items a month
so that's a really good price as opposed
to going out and buying all of those
things and they're not wearing them that
often so it makes sense for a lot of
consumers it does listen I've done Rent
the Runway when Jennifer first started
it I was curious because I thought how
would that work
to your point wearing somebody else's
clothes but if you're going to a
black-tie event you only know you're
gonna wear it one time right it really
does make a lot of sense if you want
your Kardashian moment but you don't
have Kardashian money you know that
makes a lot of sense you can get
something that costs a few thousand
dollars but you're renting it for a
couple of hundred and then you go out
you go to your wonderful event then you
send it back and go for a lot of people
that's more economically feasible I'm
still waiting for my Kardashian moment
how long do you get to keep these
clothes for usually it's about a month
and sometimes you can swap them out more
frequently so you get like three out
items and then you can kind of trade it
in and you know mix it up a little bit
more and be more flexible with your
wardrobe that mom you tell me Walmart
for baby clothes I thought that that was
a good that's a thanks so much for being
here